Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History. We are at number two in the 12 days of Christmas, but The Rest Is History being The Rest Is History, we're not really doing the 12 days. We're doing the 13 days, aren't we, Tom? We are.
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取每周独家播客、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎收听《历史其余部分》。我们在圣诞节12天的行程中排在第二位，但《历史其余部分》毕竟是《历史其余部分》，我们其实并不过12天。我们要过13天，对吧，汤姆？是的。
Do you want to explain why we're doing 13 days for those people who missed day one? Well, because the 12 days of Christmas, you can begin them either on Christmas Day or on today, Boxing Day, 26th of December. And because we're Gluttons for Punishment, we're hedging our bets and we're doing both. So this will be running to the 6th of January. And for those of you who missed the first one, we chose two very light, frivolous subjects.
你想向那些错过第一天的人解释一下为什么我们要过13天吗？嗯，因为圣诞节的13天，你可以从圣诞节当天开始，也可以从今天，也就是12月26日节礼日开始。因为我们是自讨苦吃，所以我们双管齐下，两边都选。所以这将持续到1月6日。对于那些错过第一期的人，我们选择了两个非常轻松、轻浮的主题。
We did the correlation of Charlemagne and the birth of the holy roman empire and then we did the resignation of mikhail gorbachev from the end of the ussr so two very jolly festive seasonal topics but today's well they're definitely one of them is definitely very very seasonal and festive yes and they're both musical and they're both jolly aren't they both jolly yes so i've chosen um're both jolly, yes. So I've chosen Good King Wenceslas Looking Out on the Feast of Stephen When the snow lay round about deep and crisp and even. Brightly shone
我们讲了查理曼大帝与神圣罗马帝国诞生的联系，然后讲了米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫辞职标志着苏联的解体，所以这是两个非常欢乐、喜庆、当季的话题，但今天的话题——其中一个绝对非常非常当季且喜庆，是的，它们都是音乐性的，而且都很欢乐，对吧？都很欢乐，是的。所以，我选择了一首……都很欢乐，是的。所以我选择了《好国王温斯拉夫斯》，“在圣斯蒂芬的瞻礼日，雪深且平缓……”月亮照得
the moon that night, though the frost was cruel When a poor man came in sight, gathering winter fuel. Do you not want to sing that? You're not going to sing that? I'm going to sing it a bit later on. I've got another verse to sing. That's something for people to look forward to. You can probably tell from my... I've got a slightly sore throat. Yeah.
那天晚上的月亮格外明亮，尽管严寒刺骨。当一个穷人出现时，在收集冬天的木柴。你不想唱那首歌吗？你不打算唱吗？我一会儿再唱。我还有一段要唱。那是人们可以期待的。你可以从我的……我的喉咙有点疼。是的。
So when are we, Tom? Well, so when are we? So this carol, very famous one, is written in 1853, the lyrics. Okay. By a man called John Mason Neill. Yeah. Who is Anglo-Catholic. So he's Church of England, which is Protestant,
那么我们是什么时候，汤姆？那么我们是什么时候？所以这首圣诞颂歌非常有名，歌词写于1853年。好的。由一个叫约翰·马森·尼尔的人写的。是的。他是盎格鲁-天主教徒。所以他是英国国教徒，也就是新教徒，
but he's very keen on the kind of Catholic inheritance of the Church of England. He's keen on saints and all that kind of stuff. And so he's interested in the example of Good King Wenceslas, who is a Bohemian saint from the 10th century. And so the music that he uses is actually it's not christmasy it's um associated with easter so it's it's a 13th century hymn um tempus ad est floridum say tempus ad est floridum which means of course uh it's easter so so isn't that amazing so that's the kind of interesting
但他非常热衷于英国国教的那种天主教传承。他热衷于圣徒和诸如此类的事情。因此，他对10世纪的波西米亚圣徒好国王温斯拉夫斯的榜样很感兴趣。他使用的音乐实际上不是圣诞风格的，它与复活节有关，所以这是一首13世纪的赞美诗，带有……“Tempus ad est floridum”，意思是“复活节到了”。所以这不是很神奇吗？所以这是一种有趣的
detail um but of course begs the question so who who is good king w? So that's the kind of interesting detail. But of course, begs the question. So who, who is good King Wenceslas? That's what I want to know. That's what the listeners want to know. Do you know? He was good,
细节，当然，这就引出了一个问题：那么，好国王W是谁？这就是有趣的细节。当然，这也引出了一个问题。那么，谁，好国王温斯拉夫斯是谁？这就是我想知道的。这也是听众想知道的。你知道吗？他是个好人，
but he wasn't, he wasn't a king. Was he, was he a Duke? He was a Duke. He was the Duke of Bohemia. And he's, so he's,
但他不是国王。他是个公爵吗？他是个公爵。他是波西米亚公爵。所以他，
he's around the same time as Athelstan. So he's ruling Bohemia at the same time as Athelstan is, is becoming really Bohemian at the same time as Athelstan is, is becoming King of England. So, um, nine twenties, nine thirties. I'm just looking at his dates now.
他生活的时代和埃塞尔斯坦差不多。所以他统治波西米亚的时期，正值埃塞尔斯坦成为英国国王的时期。所以，大约在920年代、930年代。我正在看他的生卒年。
Nine 21 to nine 35. Yep. Pretty, pretty much exactly the same time as that. And he really was. Yes. I'm reading it. I'm reading it as we speak.
921年到935年。是的。几乎就是那个时候。他确实是。是的。我正在读。我边说边读。
He really was called, he really was called Wenceslas. Yeah. I just assumed that was a sort of Anglicization of some impenetrable Slavic name. But he's, because he's so saintly and holy, and as we'll discover, because he gets murdered and therefore people say he was martyred, he's posthumously created a king by Otto the Great,
他真的叫温斯拉夫斯。是的。我只是以为那是某个晦涩难懂的斯拉夫名字的英国化。但他因为非常圣洁，正如我们将会发现的那样，因为他被谋杀，所以人们说他殉道了，他被奥托大帝追封为国王，
who we mentioned yesterday. Very much a friend of the show. Very much a friend of the show. Very much a friend of the 12 Days of Christmas. We should try and work Otto the Great, who we mentioned yesterday. Very much a friend of the show. Very much a friend of the show. Very much a friend of the 12 Days of Christmas. We should try and work Otto the Great into every single episode. So he is, I mean, basically he's just, he's, I think he's the grandson of the Bohemian who converted to Christianity. He's just rushes around,
我们昨天提到过他。绝对是节目的好朋友。绝对是节目的好朋友。绝对是圣诞节12天的朋友。我们应该试着在每一期节目中都提到我们昨天提到的奥托大帝。节目好朋友。圣诞节12天的朋友。我们应该试着在每一期中都加入奥托大帝。所以他，我的意思是，基本上他只是，我想他是皈依基督教的波西米亚人的孙子。他四处奔走，
you know, he's a bit like Scrooge after his visit from the three ghosts, right? Just rushes around kind of handing out stuff to poor people. And the, the, so the original story, but his deeds,
你知道，他有点像接受了三个幽灵拜访后的吝啬鬼斯克鲁奇，对吧？四处奔走，把东西分发给穷人。而最初的故事，但他的事迹，
I think, you know, better than I could tell you for, as is read in his passion, no one doubts that rising every night from his noble bed with bare feet and only one chamberlain. He went around to God's churches and gave arms generously to widows, orphans, those in prison and afflicted by every difficulty. So much so that he was considered not a prince, but the father of all the wretched. So that story of him seeing a poor man gathering winter fuel and he summons his page and they go out.
我想，你们比我更清楚，正如在他的殉难录中所读到的那样：“没有人怀疑，他每天夜里赤着脚，只带一个内侍，从他高贵的床上起来。他巡视上帝的教堂，慷慨地向寡妇、孤儿、囚徒和饱受各种苦难的人施舍。以至于人们不认为他是一位王子，而是所有不幸之人的父亲。”所以，他看到一个穷人在收集冬天的木柴，然后他召唤他的随从，他们一起走了出去。
And remember that the, the page struggles. So the page thing, sire, the night is darker now and the wind blows stronger fails. My heart. I know not how I can go no longer. Mark my footsteps.
记住，随从很艰难。所以随从说：“陛下，夜色更深，风吹得更猛，我的心在动摇。我不知道该怎么走了，我再也走不下去了。”“踩着我的脚印，
Good. My page tread thou in them boldly. Thou shalt find the winter's rage. Freeze thy blood. Let's go. Hold Lee. So that's the miracle. That's beautiful. Thank you. Thank you. So that's the miracle. That's beautiful. Thank you.
好随从，大胆地跟在我的后面。你会发现冬天的狂怒，冻结你的血液。走吧，勇敢点。”这就是奇迹。太美妙了。谢谢。谢谢。所以这就是奇迹，太美妙了。谢谢。
So that's the miracle, is that good King Wenceslas, he has a thermal quality to his bare feet. He's a radiator. He's a living, saintly radiator. But, but, but, he has a brother who
所以奇迹就是，好国王温斯拉夫斯，他的赤脚有一种保暖的特性。他是一个散热器。他是一个活生生的、圣洁的散热器。但是，但是，但是，他有一个兄弟，
brilliantly is called Bollislaus the Cruel. So you can imagine them growing up in their bohemian nursery. Yeah. And there's a massive clue, you know, a huge clue that it's not going to end that well when your brother's called the Cruel. Bollislaus, I'm looking at this, Bollislaus is four years younger. Yeah.
绝妙的是，他叫“残酷者博列斯拉夫”。所以你可以想象他们在波西米亚的育儿室里长大的情景。是的。这是一个巨大的线索，你知道，当你的兄弟被称为“残酷者”时，这是一个巨大的线索，表明结局不会那么好。博列斯拉夫，我正在看这个，博列斯拉夫比他小四岁。是的。
So he probably is driven mad by Wenceslas' niceness and kindness. Yes, I mean, he can't go out in the snow and warm it up with his radiated light feet. So he gets cross, and there's a coup, and Wenceslas gets run through by a spear. Some say held by Bolleslas himself. Oh, golly. And so Bolleslaus is actually quite a good king. Yeah, I'm reading it. This is a fascinating story, Tom.
所以他可能被温斯拉夫斯的善良和仁慈逼疯了。是的，我的意思是，他不能走到雪地里，用他那能发光的脚去温暖雪。所以他很生气，发生了一场政变，温斯拉夫斯被一根长矛刺穿了。有人说是博列斯拉夫本人拿着的。噢，天哪。所以博列斯拉夫实际上是个好国王。是的，我正在读。这是一个迷人的故事，汤姆。
It's so fascinating that while you're talking, I'm actually reading a web page on it. Okay, well, contribute. No, I will contribute. I'll tell you a fact. So according to tradition, at the very moment that Wenceslas was murdered, Bonoslaus had a son.
太迷人了，以至于你在说话的时候，我实际上正在看一个网页。好吧，那就贡献一点。不，我会贡献的。我告诉你一个事实。根据传统，就在温斯拉夫斯被谋杀的那一刻，博列斯拉夫生了一个儿子。
His son was born. Did you see that? Yeah. Do you know what his son was called? I can't remember. Straskvas. Do you know what that means? No.
他的儿子出生了。你看到了吗？是的。你知道他的儿子叫什么名字吗？我不记得了。斯特拉斯克瓦斯。你知道那是什么意思吗？不。
A dreadful feast. A dreadful feast? Yeah. Well, that's fair enough then, isn't it? And did he have a soubriquet? Well, I mean, does he need a soubriquet? I mean, if you're called a dreadful beast so he doesn't succeed bollislaus bollislaus is succeeded by his eldest
一场可怕的盛宴。一场可怕的盛宴？嗯，那倒也说得过去，对吧？他有绰号吗？我的意思是，他需要绰号吗？如果你被称为可怕的野兽，所以他没有继承博列斯拉夫，博列斯拉夫的继承人是他最年长的
son who's also his good no bollislaus the pious oh so you've got good thing is this yeah bollislaus the cruel bollislaus the pious it's a real roller coaster for the Czechs, isn't it? So Bohemian history in the 10th century is great. And the story is Wenceslas, for the Bohemians, for the Czechs, is a bit of a King Arthur figure. Yeah. So it is thought that he's asleep underneath a mountain and that when the Czechs need him, he will wake up.
儿子，也是他的好……不，虔诚者博列斯拉夫。哦，所以你有好国王温斯拉夫斯，博列斯拉夫残酷者，博列斯拉夫虔诚者，这对捷克人来说真是一次过山车般的体验，不是吗？所以10世纪的波西米亚历史很棒。这个故事是，温斯拉夫斯对波西米亚人、捷克人来说，有点像亚瑟王式的人物。是的。
Or that there's a large statue of him in Prague in Wenceslas Square. underneath a mountain and that when the Czechs need him, he will wake up. Or that there's a large statue of him in Prague, in Wenceslaus Square, frankly enough, and that statue will come alive and he will lead a procession over the bridge, Charles Bridge, and he will stumble
所以人们认为他在山下沉睡，当捷克人需要他时，他会醒来。或者在布拉格的温斯拉夫斯广场上有一座他的巨大雕像，就在山下，当捷克人需要他时，他会醒来。或者在布拉格的温斯拉夫斯广场上，很应景地，有一座他的巨大雕像，那座雕像会活过来，他会带领游行队伍穿过大桥，查理大桥，他会绊倒，
and as he stumbles, his sword will be revealed. Bruncvich. Bruncvich. and as he stumbles, his sword will be revealed. Ooh. Bruntvik. Bruntvik. Bruntvik. That's a good name for a sword.
当他绊倒时，他的宝剑就会显露出来。布伦茨维克。布伦茨维克。当他绊倒时，他的宝剑就会显露出来。哦。布伦茨维克。布伦茨维克。布伦茨维克。这名字真适合一把剑。
I will say this. If Wenceslas were planning to return, I think he would have done so already. Yes. The Czechs had a pretty tough time in the 20th century. Yeah. There were multiple opportunities for him to make his appearance. Yeah.
我要说的是：如果温斯拉夫斯打算回来，我想他早就回来了。是的。捷克人在20世纪过得很艰难。是的。他有很多次机会可以露面。是的。
And he failed to do so. Yeah. Poor. And this is worse to come his appearance. And he failed to do so. Poor. And less is worse to come. Also, if you, you know, surely you'd want Bolleslaus the Cruel to come back, wouldn't you? I mean, he's the person you'd need in your irony. You wouldn't want... Well, it depends if you're...
但他没有这样做。是的。真差劲。而且更糟的还在后面，他的出现。但他没有这样做。真差劲。而且更糟的还在后面。另外，如果你，你知道，你肯定希望残酷者博列斯拉夫回来，对吧？我的意思是，他才是你需要的人，真讽刺。你不会想要……好吧，这取决于你是……
When does this go around giving presents to people? It depends if you're walking barefoot in the winter or not. I suppose so, yeah. Because if you're doing that, you definitely want... Red barefoot in the winter or not i suppose so yeah because if you're like because if you're doing that you definitely want um red army tanks in the park spring with a super power well maybe that's why he didn't come maybe the great crisis facing the bohemians the czechs will be that they need someone to warm up the pavements with his feet yeah and that's what he'll do have you seen seen this thing that the Czechs have renamed their country in the last few years?
温斯拉夫斯到处给人们送礼物。这取决于你冬天是不是赤脚走路。我想是的，是的。因为如果你在这样做，你绝对希望……冬天赤脚走路还是不赤脚，我想是的，是的。因为如果你这样做，你肯定希望……红军坦克开进布拉格之春，带着一个超级大国。好吧，也许这就是他没来的原因，也许捷克人面临的巨大危机将是他们需要有人用他的脚来温暖人行道，是的，他会这么做的。你见过捷克人在过去几年里给他们的国家改名了吗？
Czechia. Yeah, you see it on Google Maps. Yeah. Rather than the Czech Republic. Do you think Czechia will catch on? I wish it was called Bohemia. But it can't be because of Moravia. Moravians don't want it to be called Bohemia.
捷克利亚（Czechia）。是的，你在谷歌地图上能看到。是的。而不是捷克共和国。你觉得“捷克利亚”能流行起来吗？我希望它叫波西米亚。但它不能叫波西米亚，因为有摩拉维亚。摩拉维亚人不希望它叫波西米亚。
And to call it, because it's actually made up of three regions, Bohemia, Moravia, and part of Silesia. I'm really sad that Bohemia has, has kind of vanished from the map. Yeah, it's a good name.
而且叫它，因为它实际上由三个地区组成：波西米亚、摩拉维亚和西里西亚的一部分。我真的很遗憾波西米亚从地图上消失了。是的，这是一个好名字。
It's a bit like Persia. Yeah. There's a kind of romance to it. I agree. There's a great romance to it. It's very 30 years war. I always think kind of. Well,
这有点像波斯。是的。有一种浪漫的感觉。我同意。有一种巨大的浪漫感。非常符合三十年战争的风格。我总是觉得……好吧，
very, very 10th century, I think. Yeah. Well, anyway, so that's Bohemia. That's Gunk Wenceslas.
非常非常符合10世纪的风格，我觉得。是的。好吧，无论如何，这就是波西米亚。那是好国王温斯拉夫斯。
Should we take a break now, Tom? Have you got anything more to say about Good King? Do you want to do more singing? Do you want to sing a song? No, no, because when we come back, we're doing Gilbert and Sullivan, aren't we? Yeah, and I can assure you, I'm absolutely not going to be singing.
汤姆，我们现在要休息一下吗？关于好国王，你还有什么要说的吗？你想唱更多歌吗？你想唱首歌吗？不，不，因为当我们回来时，我们要讲吉尔伯特和萨利文，对吧？是的，我可以向你保证，我绝对不会唱歌。
Are you not? No. Because the music is lost. So I've got a good reason. But you could sing some Gilbert and Sullivan. Very model of a modern major general. I am a very model of a modern major general. Goodbye.
真的吗？不唱。因为音乐已经失传了。所以我有一个很好的理由。但你可以唱一些吉尔伯特和萨利文的歌。现代少将的样板。我是现代少将的绝对样板。再见。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、少量八卦的好去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家剧集和抢先购买现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Restless History on Boxing Day, St Stephen's Day, 26th of December. We've already ticked off Good King Wenceslas looking out. And now, Dominic, you have another musical number for us, Gilbert and Sullivan themed. I do, I do. So Boxing Day is a day of jollity and a day of music.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到在节礼日、圣斯蒂芬日（12月26日）播出的《历史其余部分》。我们已经勾掉了“好国王温斯拉夫斯向外看”。现在，多米尼克，你给我们带来了另一首音乐作品，是吉尔伯特和萨利文主题的。是的，是的。所以节礼日是狂欢的日子，也是充满音乐的日子。
Boxing? And a day of, yeah, just a day of general sort of hijinks and stuff. So I thought Gilbert & Sullivan would be a great place to come in. So Gilbert & Sullivan, the great kind of Victorian sort of light opera stars of British popular culture, incredibly popular around the world, particularly in America. So if you look at the list of kind of amateur performances and things that Gilbert and Sullivan plays,
打拳击？还有，是的，就是各种恶作剧和类似事情的日子。所以我想吉尔伯特和萨利文会是一个很好的切入点。吉尔伯特和萨利文是英国流行文化中伟大的维多利亚时代轻歌剧明星，在世界各地都非常受欢迎，特别是在美国。如果你看看吉尔伯特和萨利文戏剧的业余演出和类似活动的名单，
I mean, the number in America is mind-boggling. But their very first play, Tom, it's a Greek theme, you see. That's why I thought, that's why I picked it. So their very first collaboration in 1871, starting on Boxing Day 1871. That's the day it opened, is it? Yes, the day it opened. The Gaiety Theatre was an opera called Thespis,
我的意思是，美国的数量简直令人匪夷所思。但他们的第一部戏剧，汤姆，是一个希腊主题，你看。这就是为什么我认为，这就是为什么我选了它。所以他们在1871年的第一次合作，从1871年的节礼日开始。那是它开演的日子，对吗？是的，开演的日子。盖伊剧院上演了一部名为《忒斯庇斯》的歌剧，
or The God's Grown Old. So you've got these two characters. You've got Gilbert, who's a bit older, who's the son of a naval surgeon. He does the words. And Sullivan, who's a great composer, son of a military bandmaster who was born in 1842, and he does the music. Now, Sullivan sees himself as a sort of great composer, son of a military bandmaster who was born in 1842. And he does the music.
或者《诸神老矣》。所以你有这两个角色。吉尔伯特年龄稍大一些，是一名海军外科医生的儿子。他负责写词。萨利文是一位伟大的作曲家，生于1842年，是一名军乐队指挥的儿子，他负责音乐。现在，萨利文把自己看作是一个伟大的作曲家，一个军乐队指挥的儿子，生于1842年。他负责音乐。
Now, Sullivan sees himself as a sort of serious composer, which he was. And unfortunately, he's always, you know, he's sort of... He's paired up with a comedian. Yeah, it's the classic thing. It's sort of Sir Arthur Conan Doyle trying to escape Sherlock Holmes. Sullivan is always slightly trying to escape Gilbert and Sullivan. But Gilbert kind of drags him back in with his stories of magic lozenges and things of this pirate.
现在，萨利文把自己看作是一个严肃的作曲家，他确实也是。不幸的是，他总是，你知道，他有点……他和一个喜剧演员搭档。是的，这是典型的情况。这有点像阿瑟·柯南·道尔爵士试图摆脱福尔摩斯一样。萨利文总是试图摆脱吉尔伯特和萨利文的影子。但吉尔伯特用他关于魔法润喉糖和这个海盗的故事把他拉了回来。
And skull bells. Yeah, all of this sort of stuff. So they get brought together to work on this opera. It's basically a Christmas entertainment. The plan is for it to just run for a few weeks or months. It is advertised as an entirely original grotesque opera in two acts. I like that. Grotesque opera.
还有骷髅铃。是的，诸如此类的事情。所以他们被拉到一起合作这部歌剧。这基本上是一场圣诞娱乐活动。计划是只演几周或几个月。它被宣传为一部“完全原创的两幕怪诞歌剧”。我喜欢这个。怪诞歌剧。
Grotesque opera. Say, well, if you were going to enter an opera, you want it to be pretty grotesque, I think. Yeah. So the story. Do you want to know the story, Tom? Well, so Thespis is the first actor. Yeah, the father of drama.
怪诞歌剧。好吧，如果你要演一部歌剧，你会希望它非常怪诞，我想。是的。那么剧情。你想知道剧情吗，汤姆？好吧，所以忒斯庇斯是第一个演员。是的，戏剧之父。
Is he the first actor or? He's the person who first acts in a tragedy. Yeah, exactly. So the plan is, so the story is that basically the gods have grown elderly on Mount Olympus, and they're just bored, and they feel like no one listens to them anymore. And is this set in ancient Greece or in?
他是第一个演员吗？他是第一个在悲剧中表演的人。是的，完全正确。所以计划是，故事基本上是奥林匹斯山上的诸神已经老了，他们只是感到厌烦，觉得再也没有人听他们说话了。这背景是古希腊还是？
Yeah, in ancient Greece, not modern Greece. Okay. So they fancy a change, and they decide that they will swap places with Thespis and his actors. So the actors will come up to Olympus, and the story is basically them trying to rule the universe, and they are terrible at it. And does hilarity ensue?
是的，在古希腊，不是现代希腊。好的。所以他们想换个环境，他们决定和忒斯庇斯以及他的演员们互换角色。所以演员们将来到奥林匹斯山，故事基本上就是他们试图统治宇宙，而他们在这方面做得很糟糕。然后会发生搞笑的事情吗？
It does. So the replacement for Mars, do you know what his name is? Timidon. Oh, that's... And Timidon, do you know what his name is? Timidon. Oh, that's... And Timidon, do you know what's so comic about this? He's a pacifist. He's a pacifist. It's hilarious.
确实如此。所以马尔斯的替代者，你知道他叫什么名字吗？蒂米顿。哦，那是……蒂米顿，你知道他叫什么名字吗？蒂米顿。哦，那是……蒂米顿，这里面最搞笑的是什么？他是个和平主义者。他是个和平主义者。这太搞笑了。
Yeah. The substitute for Hymen, the kind of goddess of marriage. Yeah. She doesn't want to marry anybody. That's the joke. She's a confirmed spinster. And the guy who's replacing Pluto. He's a confirmed spinster. And the guy who's replacing Pluto. Is a spendthrift.
是的。婚姻女神海门（Hymen）的替代者。是的。她不想和任何人结婚。这就是笑话所在。她是一个坚定的老处女。而代替普鲁托的那个人。他是一个坚定的老处女。而代替普鲁托的那个人。是个挥霍无度的人。
No, he doesn't like anybody dying. Doesn't let anybody die. Doesn't want anyone to come to the underworld. God, hilarity does ensue. Yeah, it's mayhem. It's absolute mayhem. It's hilarious. The gods down on Earth.
不，他不喜欢任何人死。不让任何人死。不想让任何人去冥界。天哪，真的发生了搞笑的事。是的，一片混乱。绝对是一片混乱。太搞笑了。民间的神明。
It's just what you want, a boxing day. The gods down on Earth, they're you want to have a boxing day the gods down on earth they're uh they're shocked by this carry on and they um they return to olympus and they kick out the actors and they say go back to earth your fate is to become eminent tragedians who no one ever goes to see that's funny that's still funny and that's uh that's what happens so it runs so this opens on boxing day and it runs for 63 performances. Which is a success. Which is a great success. And a lot of people think it's very funny.
这正是你想要的节礼日。地上的神明，他们——你想过一个节礼日，地上的神明，他们——呃，他们对这种胡闹感到震惊，他们——呃，他们回到了奥林匹斯山，把演员们赶了出去，他们说：“回到地球去吧，你们的命运就是成为谁也不会去看演出的著名悲剧演员。”这很有趣，现在听来依然很有趣，这就是发生的事情——所以它上演了，这个在节礼日开演，总共演了63场。这是一个成功。这是一个巨大的成功。很多人觉得非常搞笑。
Well, the public think it's funny, but the critics are not terribly impressed. So do you want to hear a couple of the reviews? Yeah. A publication called The Hornet. You wouldn't want to be reviewed by The Hornet. You wouldn't. So the problem is they review only the premiere, and the premiere is much, much too long.
嗯，公众觉得很有趣，但评论家们印象并不深刻。你想听几篇评论吗？好吧。一家名为《大黄蜂》的出版物。你可不想让《大黄蜂》给你写评论。你真的不想。问题是他们只评论了首映式，而首映式实在太长了。
So in the sort of the adverts, the management of the Gaiety Theatre have said you must book your carriages for 11 o'clock, but it's gone past 12, and the play is still going on at midnight. The jayfury is still ongoing. So The Hornet, the play is still going on at midnight. The jayfury is still ongoing. So the Hornets, the play is actually called Thespis or the God's Grown Old, but the headline on the Hornets review is Thespis,
所以在某种广告中，盖伊剧院的管理层说你必须把马车预订到11点，但时间已经过了12点，午夜时分戏剧还在继续。杰弗里事件仍在继续。所以《大黄蜂》，午夜时分戏剧仍在继续。杰弗里事件仍在继续。所以《大黄蜂》这出戏其实叫《忒斯庇斯或诸神老矣》，但《大黄蜂》评论的标题大写字母写着《忒斯庇斯，老去且令人厌烦的神》。《晨报》说：“这是一场沉闷、乏味、两幕的胡言乱语的剧情，没有机智的怪诞，音乐没有生气。大幕在打哈欠和疲惫的观众面前落下。”但除此之外，你觉得这出戏怎么样？所以音乐，我想，已经失传了。这就是为什么我不能唱，尽管我很想唱。
the God's Grown Old and Wearisome in capital letters. The morning advertiser says, it is a dreary, tedious, two-act rigmarole of a plot, grotesque without wit and the music thin without liveliness. The curtain falls before a yawning and weary audience. But apart from that, how did you enjoy the play? So the music, I think, is lost. That's why I can't sing it, much as I would like to.
真是个遗憾。因为很显然在那个时候，没有人知道吉尔伯特和萨利文会变成这样一个庞大的特许经营权。但是他们怎么没有保留音乐呢？他们怎么没有保留音乐呢？是的。我不知道。我想萨利文可能只是草草了事。
That is a shame. Because obviously at that point, no one knows that Gilbert and Sullivan is going to turn out into this tremendous franchise. But how come they haven't kept the music? How come they haven't kept the music? Yeah. I don't know. I think Sullivan just probably dashed it off.
随便应付了一下。是的，只是觉得这是一堆旧垃圾。从中赚点钱。不过没有保留下来，确实挺奇怪的。嗯，我不知道。我的意思是，我没自称是萨利文学者。好吧。不管怎样，他们的下一个作品是《陪审团审判》。
Knocked it off. Yeah, just thought this is a load of old tosh. Make some money out of it. Quite odd not to have kept it, though. Well, I don't know. I mean, I haven't claimed to be a Sullivanologist. Okay. So anyway, their next thing is a thing called Trial by Jury.
那个，我想，相当成功。然后他们进入了“颠倒世界”的世界。你看过电影《颠倒乾坤》吗？没有。其实挺好看的。那是……迈克·李。迈克·李的电影。
That's, I think, reasonably successful. And then they get into the world of Topsy-Turvy-dom. Have you seen the film Topsy-Turvy? No. It's great actually. Is that the... Mike Lee. Mike Lee film.
没有，我没看过。真的很好看。我从来没看过吉尔伯特和萨利文的。我对他们一无所知。我的意思是，我了解，因为我隐约……彭赞斯的海盗。现代少将。米卡多。
No, I haven't. It's really good. I've never seen the Gilbert and Sullivan. I don't know anything about them. I mean, I do, because I vaguely... Paris at Penzance. Modern Made in General. The Mikado.
短促而痛苦的打击。是的，这就是那种……我的意思是，我了解，因为我隐约……彭赞斯的海盗？我是现代少将。米卡多？短促而痛苦的打击？是的，这就是那种，我想，我们这一代人觉得吉尔伯特和萨利文有点被玷污了，因为那是那种很不讨人喜欢的东西。砰-德-迪，砰-德-迪，砰-德-迪。诸如此类的事情。很不讨人喜欢。
A short, sharp shock. Yeah. It's the kind of thing, I do, because I vaguely... Paris or Penzance? I'm a modern major general. The Mikado? A short, sharp shock? Yeah. It's the kind of thing, I suppose, I think Gilbert and Sullivan for people of our generation are slightly tainted, because it's the kind of thing that's very unlovely. Pomp-de-dee, pomp-de-dee, pomp-de-dee. All that kind of stuff. Very unlovely.
约翰·梅杰时期的内阁大臣们会在保守党党大会上背诵它。是的，他们会。作为对单亲母亲攻击的一部分。是的，那是彼得·莉莉，对吧？是的。他唱了一段吉尔伯特和萨利文的歌，观众很喜欢，但全国其他地方都绝对震惊。
Sort of John Major-era cabinet ministers would recite it at Tory party conferences. Yes, they would. As part of an attack on single mothers. Yes, it was Peter Lilly, wasn't it? It was. He sung a bit of Gilbert and Sullivan and the audience loved it, but the rest of the country was absolutely appalled.
并投票给了托尼·布莱尔。但我认为吉尔伯特和萨利文非常欢乐。这都是对机构等等的温和讽刺。所以我应该看一部吗？你推荐我看吗？我认为《米卡多》，我认为你应该看电影《颠倒乾坤》，因为那太棒了。
And voted for Tony Blair. But I think Gilbert and Sullivan is very jolly. It's all sort of gentle satire of institutions and so on. So should I watch one? Would you recommend I should? I think the Mikado, I think you should watch Topsy Turvy, the film, because that is brilliant.
好的。吉姆·布劳德本特是……我需要了解它吗？不，你完全不需要了解它。好的，我会看的。那是对维多利亚时代英国以及那个世界的精彩重现。然后最著名的
Okay. Jim Broadbent is... Do I need to know about it? No, you can know nothing about it at all. Okay, I'll do that. It's a brilliant recreation of Victorian England and of that world. And then the most famous ones
可能是《彭赞斯的海盗》和《米卡多》。还有《米卡多》，是的。《米卡多》现在有危险了，不是吗？它被视为终极文化挪用，因为它是关于日本的。这很美妙。“三个小女仆，我们是三个小女仆？”“三个小女仆，嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟嘟……”
are probably the Pirates of Penzance and the Mikado. And the Mikado, yeah. The Mikado is now in danger, isn't it, of being, it's been seen as the ultimate cultural appropriation because it's all about Japan. It is beautiful. Three Little Maids, Three Little Maids Are We? Three Little Maids, do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
我不知道歌词，但就是这样的。不管怎样，我看过《米卡多》，它非常……他们是中国人，对吧？不，日本人，当然。日本人，日本人。所以吉尔伯特曾去参观过一个关于日本某种艺术和东西的展览，这给了他创作《米卡多》的灵感，但它实际上并不是关于
I don't know the words, but that's how it goes. Anyway, I've seen the Mikado and it's very... They're Chinese, aren't they? No, Japanese, of course. Japanese, Japanese. So Gilbert had been to an exhibition of Japanese sort of arts and stuff and that gave him the idea for the Mikado but it's actually not about
日本的。我的意思是，笑话是它对伟大波巴的讽刺，就像那种公务员。我的意思是，这显然有点像《不可Er求》或那种你不需要看过它它就在周围漂浮的情况
Japan I mean the joke is it's a kind of parody of the great poobah is like the sort of the civil servant I mean it's clearly it's a bit like the importance of being earnest or that you don't have to have seen it it's kind of floats around as you know
隐约合成的概念，并且有一些像“短促而痛苦的打击”这样的习语，这些习语就像隐约合成的概念一样流传开来。由于吉尔伯特和萨利文，它们已经渗透到语言中。它们在美国实际上同样受欢迎。所以你会看到里面有很多引用，比如那种美国式的、喜欢发推特的美国专栏作家，他们会引用吉尔伯特和萨利文的话。是的。
vaguely synthesised idea and there are these idioms like a short sharp shock that have of floats around as, you know, vaguely synthesized ideas. And there are these idioms, like a short sharp shock, that have sort of penetrated into the language because of Gilman Sullivan. They're actually just as popular in America. So you'll see loads of references to it in kind of, you know, that sort of kind of American, tweety American columnist who will quote Gilman Sullivan. Yes.
所以《米卡多》真的有问题吗？我不认为它真的有问题，因为人们反抗它的取消，因为他们指出它并不是为了讲日本。它是关于英国的，对吧？它是关于英国的。它是对英国的讽刺。是的，完全正确。
So the Mikado is genuinely problematic, is it? I don't think it is genuinely problematic because people fought back against its cancellation because they pointed out it's not meant to be about Japan. It's about Britain, isn't it? It's about Britain. It's the satire of Britain. Yeah, exactly.
就是那种东西。这是对英国的讽刺，它使用的方法是，笑话是它是日本的一个糟糕版本，它不是一个真正的——好吧，那是非常非常紧跟时代的讽刺。
It's that kind of thing. It's the satire of Britain and it uses the, and the joke is that it's a bad version of Japan and it's not a real well that's very that's very up to date satire
所以，这就是——所以我想每个人都应该看——所以显然《颠倒乾坤》是一部精彩的节礼日电影，它非常欢乐。你知道吗，多米尼克？
so so that's so I think everybody should watch so obviously Turb is a brilliant Boxing Day film it's very jolly well do you know Dominic
伟大的音乐，你启发了我，我会在节礼日看它。我今天要看它，因为今天当然是节礼日。太棒了。
great music you've inspired me I will I will watch it on Boxing Day I'll watch it today because of course today is Boxing Day brilliant
太棒了。你没有泄露我们是在……之前录音的秘密吧？我知道我差点说漏嘴了，但我想我们蒙混过关了。是的，不管怎样，祝大家的节礼日过得非常愉快，我们明天会带两件发生在12月27日的事件的选择与大家见面。再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取独家剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。
brilliant you haven't given the game away that we're recording before i know i almost blew it there but i think i think we got away with it yeah so anyway uh have a very happy rest of boxing day um and we will see you tomorrow with our choices for two events that fell on the 27th of December. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
太棒了，你没有提前泄露我们在录音的事。我知道，我差点说漏嘴了，但我觉得我们蒙混过关了。总之，祝大家节礼日剩余时间过得愉快，我们明天将为大家带来12月27日发生的两个历史事件的选择。再见。感谢收听《历史的底蕴》。如需收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。